Hey good morning everyone this is
because you can run you can't hide we're
at PI D to London it's Saturday July 13
2019 nice to meet all of you I'm James
Powell you can follow me on Twitter if
you like this talk my twitter handle is
don't use this code so I'll start off
like every talk starts off with Who am I
except you probably don't really care
that much so I'll boil it down to the
most important parts number one you can
follow me on Twitter if you'd like and
number two I come from a scientific and
numeric computing background not a
machine learning background and so a lot
of this talk is about the kind of
problems that we solve in a scientific
and numeric computing ecosystem namely
we can a lot of us come to Python
looking at Python as a glue language
specifically looking as Python as a
language that wraps existing C or C++
code it's often the case that somebody
has written analytical code or model
code 10 or 15 years ago and C and C++ we
want to provide that to our users in a
friendlier fashion and so when we choose
to use Python we're choosing to use
Python to exact adapt existing code or
to adapt an existing API and our choice
of Python especially for those of us who
come to Python prior to say some of the
nice conveniences added in later
versions of Python 3 often isn't that
great we came to Python because there
are no core dumps because there's no
malloc and free to add a lot of
cognitive overhead because there's name
spacing but that really only ever means
that ok yeah just little bit less typing
and because python has some rich
introspective features and so we chose
Python because we can work more
iteratively it's not this painful write
some code compile rerun that code cycle
that you often see what C or C++ now in
terms of when we're using Python we
often see that our use of Python splits
us between thinking about Python being
used as some library code or some
analysis and application code and a lot
of us start our career at that lowest
tier writing analysis code doing the
analyses themselves using some libraries
and as our career progresses we move
higher up and we start writing library
code instead of doing the analyses
ourselves we're now in charge of
facilitating or empowering our users to
do the analyses better in some cases we
may see even three tiers where there's
some analysis level some library level
and some
library level and maybe the case debt
when we talk about a library the library
that you're writing is something that
itself is built on existing libraries
like pandas or numpy and as you move
higher up in the stack this requirement
to be able to do API design becomes more
and more pressing because you're no
longer responsible for just deriving
analysis you need to facilitate large
teams of people to be able to do those
analyses as effectively as possible so
you have this necessity to do API design
you need to be able to design API so
that people can do their work more
effectively where the core of that work
is implemented and maybe C or C++ and
you're providing some layer in order to
shave down the edges the harder edges of
that now again why Python if you think
about Python Python or any language in
general provides a set of metaphors and
a set of mechanisms that make API design
easier and the terminology I'm using
here is that a metaphor is maybe
something that's provided to the user a
convenience or an affordance that makes
it easier for the user to conceptualize
how they bridge solving the problem and
writing the code that actually solve
some business problem and a mechanism is
something that's provided to the author
some tool that makes it easier for the
author of this library to provide some
code base that they can maintain long
term that their users can continue to
use in order to solve real-world
business problems and so when we talk
about metaphors in Python there's quite
a few
if you dig back to the beginnings of
some of the libraries that we use every
day like matplotlib they came to be in
an environment where Python really
didn't provide all that many metaphors
on top of say C or C++ if you look at
the map Holub API and you wonder why
does it have first of all to api's and
why is it such a simplistic API and it
doesn't use any of these recent features
why doesn't it for example use
properties it's because matplotlib
predates things like properties and
Python and so when matplotlib was first
developed the depth of metaphors
provided to it were quite quite quite
few I mean you had metaphors like being
able to call a function you had
metaphors like being able to pass
keyword arguments and so you could write
some nice code that looks like this
that's way better than what you'd write
in C or C++ where this additional
optional keyword argument might be
obscured by a bunch of null values
passed in between or having to create
some structure
some object to pass through Python gave
you a much easier way to express the
same thing that the core library needed
in order to implement some functionality
it provided some basic name spacing so
you didn't have libraries where every
function was was prefixed by the name of
the library and so your users could type
a little bit less but as Python grew we
started to add deeper metaphors and so
you had object orientation and when you
look at a lot of the libraries a lot of
the older libraries in Python really
they limit themselves in terms of the
metaphors they employ to just functions
and objects and nothing more but as you
start to look at newer newer libraries
they use nicer metaphors in Python like
context managers the ability to prefix
and suffix some operation to bracket
some operation with some setup and
teardown API is like matplotlib predate
this but newer api's are able to use the
richness of metaphors available in
Python there was a talk that I gave
that's on YouTube that has like a
million hits on YouTube where I go into
depth about some of the nice rich
metaphors that are available in Python
generators co-routines context managers
and decorators and that you actually
have a very rich field in order to
provide these conveniences and for
dances now when we talk about mechanisms
in Python mechanisms are pieces that are
made available to the actual author of
this library stuff like the ability to
have very attic arguments so our keyword
very attic arguments this makes a little
bit easier freedom to for example write
wrapper functions where you don't have
to fix some dependency on what the
function you're wrapping will exact
arguments of text you can just say it's
a star arc star star quarks takes any
set of arguments whatsoever and you can
free yourself of some of these
dependencies that you would otherwise
have to deal with if you really think
about it think really deeply about how
difficult it is to use very attic
arguments and see and how for example
print F has variants like VA printf and
how you can't actually mix and match
those Python even something as simple as
this is a giant step ahead of what you
had available and see and maybe even C++
similarly in more modern Python you have
things like keyword only arguments it
makes it really easy for you to write a
library because you can say look my
users are no longer fixing on some
particular order of the arguments they
can only ever pass these arguments by
keyword and Python 3.8 may be a little
bit more dubious of a change you have
things like positional only arguments
and so you're forcing users to not fix
themselves on the name of an argument
one of the core mechanisms that a lot of
API designers try to reach for is an
information hiding mechanism and
surprisingly even though python has such
a rich set of mechanisms available to it
this is one which you can see is
stunningly missing when I say
information hiding I mean things like
encapsulation and constants and so from
an API design perspective you often want
to provide your user with like some
function from some API and when you look
at that function itself it has some
internal details some like some internal
implementation and you want to hide that
from your user because otherwise if they
fix some dependency on this
implementation you lose your ability to
move quickly in refactoring the
underlying library itself but it turns
out that obviously if you have some
implementation function some users gonna
dig around in the module they're gonna
find the method that it begins with an
underscore isn't going to give them a
pause not a not a pang of compunction
not a moment of guilt they'll just
import it and use it and then they'll
complain when you change out the
implementation later in their code
breaks and unfortunately or maybe
fortunately for the user and
unfortunately for the library author
Python is very rich in its introspective
capabilities and so in the standard
library itself you have things like get
source from the inspect module so you
can just find what the source code is
for any arbitrary function and then
figure out how is implemented and pierce
that veil that that library author is
trying to put around some implementation
details or similarly in the standard
library there's a disk module and so
even if for example they only provide
you with the Python bytecode and they
don't provide you with the source code
you can still disassemble the bytecode
and kind of figure out what's going on
behind the scenes in fact earlier this
year there was a really interesting
library that was made available called
uncompelled
that D compiles Python bytecode and it
turns out that it is surprisingly easy
to make very readable source code given
Python bytecode and so even if you
provide the user with only the bytecode
not the source code they can still do
some digging behind the scenes to figure
out what's going on now if we think
about and we try and focus on just one
particular problem for example you have
some API and you have some state and you
think about how you might go about
hiding that state we'll see that it
turns out to be very difficult in Python
so you have some API you
have some hidden state and you don't
want the user to be able to see that
state or to muck with it and so one of
the common approaches that somebody
would suggest you take is used a
property decorator and so you have some
class you have some property there's
some underscore X state and the user
can't quite see it they can't quite
touch it their interfaces through this
property and so they can do sets and
gets and if they perform an operation
like dot x equals here this will fail
Python will say there's no corresponding
setter and this will fail but an even
slightly competent user is just going to
do a dir on this type and they're gonna
just change the code to look like this
and move on with their life and they're
gonna pierce that veil that you've
created by using this property and you
might think ok now you've changed from
being a user to being an adversary let
me see if I can step it up a bit and I
can make it a little bit harder for you
to pierce that fail and so you might be
motivated to try something a little bit
crazier instead of hiding this state in
behind a property but where the state is
still visible you might hide the state
by creating some lambda and this X is
now hidden in the closure of the lambda
and so if they do that dir that can't
quite find it but a sufficiently
motivated user it's just gonna say you
know what I can swap out that lambda and
get along with what I was trying to do
and it turns out that if they wanted to
do this even more surgically they can
with just a combination of dir and just
looking at what's available at that
object in their interactive console they
can dig deeply enough and find you know
what I can actually go into the function
closure where that state was the cell
contents and I can see what those cell
contents are now if they try and change
those cell contents as we know Python
closures are read only but that user can
say you know what python has a very rich
runtime in a Python runtime everything
exists everything is visible and there's
got to be a way for me to do what I want
to do I want to go in and I want to muck
around with this internal state and so
what they're gonna determine is even if
you try and make this much harder for
them and you try and say I'm gonna hide
this in a method that I'll delete out of
the scope that I'll hide in the default
arguments here what they're gonna do is
they're gonna say you know what I can
dig around and I can find that Const I
can try and change it that won't work
but what I can do is it's Python it's
got
rich run time I won't try and change it
I'll just make a copy I'll make a
perfect copy of the thing you have and
just swap out the one piece that I
wanted to swap out and so here's a
little bit of code here where we just
copy somebody else's function and swap
out the read-only parts with the parts
we wanted to modify and then if you do
that you can go very deep into that
function and you can find where the data
is stored and make a copy there you can
make a copy of the next level up which
happens to be where that function is
bound and the default arguments that you
can make a copy one more level up which
is on the F get of the property itself
and if you put it all together you have
something looks like this and you've
ended up patching out this three layer
attempt to block the user from seeing
some internal state and mucking around
with it and this is the safe and easy
way to do this now when I say that this
is not hard this is an easy way I really
genuinely mean it that's not kubera
stats not showing off yes if you look at
some code that looks like this this
might be Bill wildering and it may be
the case that if you look at this you
can't quite write that out from scratch
off the top of your head if you looked
at code like this that makes a copy of
that function and swaps out the
constants and the defaults you might not
be able to write that off the top of
your head but really genuinely consider
this when you have a user who is
sufficiently motivated to break the veil
of some API because there's something
that they need to get done for some
process and the library you have
provided them is not able to do what
they need to get done they have infinite
time they have debuggers they have dir
they have introspective abilities they
have a runtime they have access to all
of your source code they have Stack
Overflow and while they may not be able
to write this off the top of their head
any sufficiently motivated user over the
course of a couple of afternoons or a
couple of days if they really want to
break that veil of that API they will
come up with this if they can't come up
with this themselves they will google
until they find some Stack Overflow
posts where somebody else came up with
this and they'll use that and so it
turns out that in Python these
mechanisms are sufficiently they're not
very protected there's no way for you to
hide information using any of these
mechanisms because even the it really
isn't the sophistication of the user in
terms of their knowledge of Python it
really is the motivation of that user
that's going to determine whether
they're going to be able to pierce this
veil or not now
you could even do this more sir
it turns out that when you're mucking
around with Python internals and you're
doing your dir and seeing what you can
read and write yes it turns out the
Python interpreter itself has certain
portions that are read right for example
the function closure has some read-only
portions that are not writable and you
can play around with some tricks to copy
things around and you might say that in
the real world case the level of
complexity of the code that you're
trying to surgically make modifications
to is so high that it's not actually
feasible for you to go and find a
surgical way to change that and this is
the same reasoning behind why if I for
example deliver model code to a user and
that model code is in the form of a
binary blob I'm not really worried that
they're gonna they're gonna reassemble
the assembly back into C code and make
modifications it's probably not a very
realistic thing when a company like
Adobe gives you a binary blob for
Photoshop they're not really worried
that you're gonna go and and patch bits
in there because the level of complexity
is too high
but it turns out that pythons runtime is
so dynamic and so capable of
introspection that these techniques tend
to be much more much easier than you'd
expect and there's always some layer
where somebody can dig just deep enough
and look around and inch their way
towards figuring out how to defeat one
of these mechanisms in fact something
that we discovered it when we were
diving into this from a different
perspective is that there's even more
surgical and maybe less safe ways to go
about doing this it turns out that
tuples aren't really immutable in Python
now what I what I don't mean is I don't
mean that you can that you can do
something like like that that's not
that's not true I mean obviously this is
going to fail this tuple is immutable
and I don't quite mean something like
this where yeah the tuple contains a
list and the list is immutable and you
can do that and you don't get any
trouble and I don't mean something like
this where if you actually try this in
your Python console the Python console
will tell you it failed but it'll
actually succeed which is the worst of
both worlds and I don't mean that what I
mean is if you dig into say the
disassembly for a function like this and
you look at the disk
for that function and you see that at
the very top of that disassembly there's
this MEC there's this method called load
fast and you dig into the C code for C
Python and you look at what the load
fast does you can see there's a get
local online 1,075 and you look at what
that get local macro does and you can
see it does an array index into this
array called fast locals and you'd think
for a second you say hold on it's doing
an array index but it's not checking the
extents of that array index so if you
gave it a bad local variable to load you
could arbitrarily read and write into
memory to your heart's content
well that's how you can actually make
two poles mutable and so this is
something that we discovered last year
and this is the practical use case for
it it turns out that if you
automatically generate a Python function
and that Python function has 2 to the
16th branches in it and you dynamically
create that function until that function
was in 2 to the 16 bytes of some code
you want to manipulate then you can tell
that function to change a local variable
that doesn't exist that happens to be at
exactly the offset where the memory you
want to mutate is and you can go and you
can change that memory and the
surprising thing about this approach is
there is no C code here there is no C
types there is no C FFI there is nothing
that is not in the standard library
that's not just creating Python code by
exec string of text and abusing byte
code values so it turns out that it's
surprisingly easy to poison byte codes
without any swith any without anything
even looking like C and break any Python
sandbox totaling bits here to your zone
to your heart's desire so this is an
example of tuple set item I thought it
was a really cute little example that we
came up with last year that shows look
there's the situation of Python is such
that there are so few mitigations the
language is so dynamic that any attempt
to do information hiding can be defeated
now if any of you have had an
opportunity to see some of the talks
going on at Euro Python there was a talk
this weekend about pep 551 and I think
557 I was part of the authorship for
that pep and some of the previous work
of it it was about
auditing hooks being added to Python
Python 3.8 now has auditing hooks and
this is part of a larger effort to add
security transparency features to Python
this is not adding features to python
from the perspective of api design it's
adding features to python from the
perspective of making it able to run in
very secure execution context and it
turns out that there is some similarity
between the things that you need to do
when you're trying to do information
hiding and the things you might want to
do when you're trying to lock down a
python interpreter and medic or exploits
like the one that i just showed you
there so that it is incredibly difficult
to lock things down oftentimes I found
when I have looked at code bases and I
have wanted to pierce the veil of some
encapsulation that that API gave me so I
can make the API do something it wasn't
supposed to do because I need that in
order to do some work I've often found
that the resource that I go to is
traditional you know hacker text files
to figure out how would a hacker go
about breaking this and that's how an
API user would go about breaking this as
well now it turns out that for the most
part a lot of the code that we're
writing is running on Linux and the
situation is even worse than you thought
because it turns out that on Linux you
might have a proc file system in this
proc file system all those numbers there
are all the processes that are running
on my computer right now if I there's a
symlink they're self and that's the
current process in that current process
you can see there's two interesting
files here one called maps and one
called mem and this Maps file tells me
all of the maps all of the locations in
virtual memory where I have allocated
something so you can see this is in the
LES process so you can see the first
three are the actual less binary you can
see there's Lib C here as well if this
were a Python process I would see all
the dynamic libraries a Python itself
loaded and the really sad thing is if
you look at the permissions of mem which
represents your virtual memory it's
readwrite if you go into the kernel
itself and you look at how the proc file
system works you can see there's that
mem object and here's where the mem
operations are here's where the right
operation is you have to go a little bit
deeper when you actually write to the
proc self mem object it only looks at
the file permissions
the file not of the memory segment so
even though some of these memory
segments are marked as read only execute
only none of that is none of that is
obeyed if you right through the proc
file system so it turns out that this
you know are not or are X or X
protection sorry W X or X protection
this memory is either writable or
executable even that can be defeated
trivially or in other words some of
these mitigations that I'm showing you
that work in Python are generalizable to
any language whatsoever if you give me a
programming language like C++ or Java
and I have the ability to open and write
to a file I can flip bits in that
language there is no information hiding
in Python there is no information hiding
in C++ or Java that will defend against
a sufficiently motivated attacker
because that attacker can always dig
into into system memory itself and flip
bits to their heart's content find
whatever they want the only boundary you
have provided by the operating system is
the process level boundary and in Python
it's quite easy to come up with a an
interesting use case of this so here is
image right that's my Twitter page here
is a follow me on Twitter here's image
right and there's an example of you take
a string a byte string and Python and
you can make byte strings in Python
mutable by just going into the virtual
memory of the process itself and
flipping bits in the virtual memory of
the process itself and so there is no
information hiding mechanism that you
can guarantee will defend against a
sufficiently motivated adversary where I
use the word adversary as a synonym for
end user so what does this all mean
what's the point other than showing you
a couple of cute little hacks what's the
point of all of this well it turns out
that we may be thinking about the way
that we design our API is wrong if this
is the perspective that we're taking
api's are not wholly programmatic if you
think about it the meaningful
construction as part of a software
process is a human construction it is a
human being who cares about the API and
if you think about software as a
discipline it's very difficult for us to
call software engineering there is no
such thing as software engineering we
don't really Oh BAE any of the general
principles of any other engineering
field this
by calling it software engineering but
if we wanted to find an argument by
which we could defend software as an
engineering practice it would be that
software is not a mathematical or
scientific process it's a process that
is subordinated to some human effort the
software only makes sense and what in
terms of what it helps a human being do
and that's akin to what we might call
engineering in other words if you think
about writing code there's some
automation spectrum between what a
machine can do automatically and a human
can do all of these mitigations and all
of these attacks and counter-attacks
that I've talked about or considering
only in the machine side but there's a
human side as well for example if I
provided you with an API and it had a
load data function and had it clean that
a function and maybe I used a metaphor
so you have keyword arguments that you
can provide as well and there was a
process data function and I was doing a
code review of the code that you gave me
and in the middle I saw this it doesn't
matter that you can do this this is
gonna get blocked to code with you right
because you're not gonna say oh that
looks reasonable and then they put that
in the middle and oh okay yeah okay of
course and so what it means is all of
these API mechanisms that I'm trying to
use to do information hiding yeah you
can't you you genuinely cannot do it you
cannot enforce it at the Machine level
but it's very trivially easy to enforce
this at the code review at the human
level and so I think what are the core
lessons that we should have here is we
shouldn't care about our users and I
know some of you are saying you know
what why did I have to see this talk in
the first place I already don't care
about my users
so maybe I'll adjust this slightly
adjust the way that you are concerned
about how your users use your code
ultimately the users of some API are
highly paid professionals the reason
that they are trying to work around
something that your API is done they're
digging into the implementation details
they're making it harder for you to
maintain that code they're perhaps
piercing the veil they're breaking your
information hiding mechanisms is because
they have assessed that this is what's
necessary to do in order to accomplish
some human task and I'm not going to
prioritize something that the machine
tells me that I can or can't do over
what the human or the business needs me
to do and I'd say even in the PI data
audience an increasing topic recently
has been things like linters and code
for matters and things like pipe 484
type hinting and all of these mechanisms
when they're presented to you at a
conference like a PI data conference
they're often presented to you as an
assistive mechanism oh you should use a
auto formatter like black it really
helps you out oh you should use pepp 44
it really helps you in writing your code
and refactoring your code more
effectively but unfortunately when you
see these same mechanisms employed in
industrial setting they're no longer so
you know they're told oh you're gonna
start using pepp 44 because it helps you
out oh you're gonna use Auto formatting
because it helps you out they turn into
coercive mechanisms oh you're gonna use
pepp 44 because your code sucks and we
need to force you to write code the
right way oh your your code formatting
is all over the place you need to use an
auto format or like black because
otherwise your code is unreadable and it
turns out that this statement of my
co-workers can't code is a universal
statement it doesn't matter where you
work it doesn't matter how much you're
paid everybody seems to complain about
the poor code to their co-workers right
but this is owing to a misconception
it's a misconception of one or your
co-workers being are they given the
proper incentives to write good code and
if not maybe the code they've written is
because they're working under some
incentive structure that incentivizes
them to ship things over shipping good
things or maybe they're working around
legitimate problems in an API or a
platform that you have provided them
that they have assessed this is the only
way I can get done what I need to get
done
in other words the easiest place to find
a spotless kitchen is that a restaurant
that has no customers or the easiest
place to find perfect code is if nobody
uses that code to put it more to put it
more formally you can think that in any
business function if the core process of
that business function involves software
and that business function is in a
competitive market that software is
going to continuously be pushed to do
more and more to expand into other areas
to scale and whatever whatever it means
for that to scale and so that software
will always operate in a degraded mode
there is no core process of a successful
business in a competitive market where
that software is not operating in some
kind of degraded mode and so that code
will always be bad it will always have
problems it'll always need some somebody
to come in and fix it this is why I'm
actually very skeptical when we talk
about safety in an industrial setting
and whether that's applicable to
software because I don't know that it's
actually genuinely structurally possible
for commercial software safety to even
exist given the incentives to push that
software always outside of it it's a
proper operating mode so the lessons
that we might learn from this is when we
started off in this in this discussion I
said the easiest way that you might
implement software hiding a Python is
using properties and when we found that
we could break that we started going
into deeper and deeper mechanisms and
seeing that none of those actually
worked well it turns out that some of
these basic techniques are sufficient
that very first technique you want to
hide something use a property and then
use code review in order to ensure that
people don't abuse that the basic
techniques end up working and as you go
into these deeper and more convoluted
techniques you end up not gaining
anything but you have an arms race
between you and your users to see who
can work around whom most effectively
similarly maintain constant
communication with their users if your
view is that your users are adversary
and they need to be coerced into using
your library in the correct way and
you're not constantly in communication
with them to say how are you using this
what do you need out of this and what is
it not solving for you you're going to
find that you're going to be pushed to
these mechanisms to say I'm gonna force
you to stop doing this by hide
some information here by blocking
something here by by doing something
crazy that they will then find a way to
work around similarly right as little
code as possible because as you saw
those mitigations become more and more
complex the amount of code that the
author of those mitigations had to write
became greater their requirements to
focus on things to coerce their user
into doing the right things started to
outpace the actual functionality they
were providing and this wasn't a good
story for anybody and ultimately keep
that code shower keep these mitigation
keep keep the code shallow enough so
that if you have some convenience layer
and that convenience layer has certain
conveniences associated with it that the
user might want to work around it's okay
that they might pierce that veil they
will do that they will dig into the
implementation they will take a nice
convenience API that you provided them
and dismantle it to get something done
assume that that's going to happen keep
your convenience layers as shallow as
possible so that you can recode or
reformulate those convenience layers
when you see that they are piercing that
veil and assume that this misuse is
going to happen don't try too hard to
avoid the misuse in fact anticipate that
you'll get things wrong and write your
code so that if the API that you wrote
was wrong and a user had to dismantle
that API to look at something that
you're trying to hide some state or some
implementation detail you're trying to
hide anticipate that that will happen
and in fact try to give them safer
safety valves give them a way to safely
break your API give them a way to escape
out of certain mechanisms that you're
enforcing upon them because they will do
that no matter what I'm so try and work
with that and ultimately remember that
because you can run Python because it is
such a run rich runtime you can't hide
thank you so much
if anyone has questions you want to open
the Q&A I think there are time we
couldn't we can answer any questions
anybody yeah thanks who who thinks their
co-workers don't write good code you can
close your eyes so that if you're
sitting next to your coworker yeah who
thinks their co-workers write really
great code and oh my goodness I'm so
happy don't lie don't lie these amazing
talks thank you what tool do you use to
make those gorgeous slides I'll answer
that at the pub quiz any other questions
oh follow me on Twitter oh I I don't
know I think it's somewhere on the
screen somewhere I can sorry so you
talking about the safety edge flexible
and thin shadow layers you're saying but
can you give some examples the way
you've seen that work well and yeah so I
think I think if you look at Python
itself as a core language and if you
look at it in comparison to other
languages look at the SIS model in Corp
I thought and look at all the ways that
you can patch or revise certain
assumptions that are made you know if
you want to print something to a file
the print function has a file keyword
argument or you can just rewrite
standard out and it just works if you
look at a lot of core libraries you
don't see these kind of safety hatches
or safety valves or escape hatches or
safety valves really added to them and
think about cases where I'll give you an
example of sort of where it fails we
ever tried to subclass a numpy and dra
or subclass of panda's data frame it
doesn't work does it because you have
this problem of always falling out of
the type and in certain cases you may
actually need to do that you may need to
subclass the ND array in order to
intercept certain operations and when
you do that you end up finding yourself
in this weird degenerate case where you
have to overwrite or you have to
implement every single operation on the
panda's data frame or the numpy ND array
in order to make sure you don't fall out
of that type and then as those libraries
are updated
out of sync with the library that you
have you have to maintain that here's a
case of there being no safety valve no
escape hatch because somebody somewhere
wanted to do something they had this
data frame object that was wrapping
around some underlying storage you
didn't really provide them a way to get
down into that underlying storage
without digging around and you have this
arms race or this unfortunate situation
where you're working around something
that they did and then they may end up
trying to either work around something
that you've done or they may end up
writing some code that breaks your work
around yep still of five minutes
hey thanks a lot for it so I just wanted
to can you just explain what you meant a
bit more about keeping your code shallow
I didn't completely get that part one of
the things that you see is if you look
at if you look at an API like pandas or
you look at an API like matplotlib or if
you look at an API like bouquet bouquet
used to have the bouquet charts and the
core bouquet and the general idea was
there was some live that API that
implemented the core functionality like
the actual construction of the
visualization there was some layer on
top that filled in a bunch of details
that would make it so you didn't have to
specify the mark type or the color or
whatnot so you had this two-tiered API
mat polyp very much has this the pipe
lot API does anyone here actually use
raw matplotlib no you'll always go
through pipe lot and then you pass in
arguments well look at the stack depth
for something like pipe lot and see if
you do pipe lot hist how many layers
deep you have to go to figure out where
that code is actually generating the
items that fit into the matplotlib draw
graph and it tends to be very very deep
if any of you have dealt with things
like Python packaging see how deep it is
between where your setup tools entry
point is and where it actually calls
into the code itself you're looking at
maybe five or six stack frames deep and
well that may not sound like such a big
problem consider that if you wanted to
look at something like matplotlib pipe
lock that hissed and you wanted to
slightly modify something about how it
generated its graph if you have four or
five stack frames D
where that argument that you're passing
in at the hist is the the possibility
for that's gonna use is going to
exponentially grow with each stack frame
each function that gets called now has a
new set of places you have to look and
so with the very deep API like that you
end up having to look in a lot of places
and potentially having to patch out a
lot of things to make the the necessary
changes and so a better API would be if
you had as few stack frames as possible
between that convenience layer and the
actual core layer if you had a
convenience layer like pipe lot and I'm
not saying that this is so trivial to do
because clearly in the case of
matplotlib it is a library that was
written by very talented people and so
they've tried their hardest do this but
in that convenience layer if it was as
shallow as possible if it had as little
code in terms of the number of stack
frames there would be a lot easier for
somebody to read the code for that and
then re-implement their own version or
to patch out the pieces they want to
actually get down into the core
functionality layer
[Music]
could you talk a bit about why people
want to hide the state from the users
yes I've written some convenience layer
for you that convenience layer makes a
lot of assumptions it may be hard code
some configuration I'm very opinionated
by the configuration it uses some
underlying mechanisms like think about
pandas plotting and when you do pandas
dataframe dot plot there are certain
assumptions that are made in terms of
what back-end do you use what options do
you use how do you construct that plot
right now if you have the ability to
pierce that plot API and you're digging
deep into the internals of how map of
pandas plotting works and you're then
writing your code against that and then
pandas updates to support new backends
the pandas authors are going to write
code that breaks your code you're gonna
go onto github and you're gonna fill out
a github issue saying Mark Garcia I hate
you so much why did you break my code
and it's going to ruin his life
and so the reason that they want to hide
those implementation details and make it
harder for you to find them is because
that's how they preserve their own
sanity for when they need to make
underlying changes they want to provide
you as small an API as possible so they
can track what you're dependent on so
that they don't end up accidentally
making one small change that seems very
reasonable to them but then broke a lot
of people's code and they get a lot of
angry comments on yeah
thank you
[Applause]